thank you for that well the countdown is
on for sunday's 64th annual grammy
awards and of course they're happening
right here in las vegas rehearsals are
underway and crews are working out all
the final details for music's biggest
night now it's it'll air and stream live
from coast to coast as viewers of the
oscars witnessed well anything can
happen on live television but grammy
producers say they're prepared
what do we do if x y and z happens and i
think it just makes you have that
conversation so that you're more ready
for things when it can go right or wrong
alright so the setting at the mgm grand
garden arena will be intimate with a
pre-pandemic feel
we are getting you up to speed on the
biggest names in music ahead of the
grammys our special salute to music we
have sammy hagar jeff timmons of 98
degrees sharing who they expect to win
ceelo green as well and the hottest
fashion trends expected on the red
carpet it's all tomorrow at 9 00 pm
right here on channel 8.